smart people think nobody else can do
their work better than them nobody so
they have to control everything they're
doing millionaires eventually figure out
that if you want to scale and build a
very big business and become a
millionaire one day you have to learn
that you can do it all by yourself
and you need a lot of help so they go
from being smart to being a wise and to
become wise you learn how to delegate
and lever it so today we're going to
talk about a word that most control
freaks cannot stand and it's called
delegation I know it's the curse word to
you I know maybe a curse word to you and
I know that's not the most exciting
topic you may want to watch but I
promise you by the time we're done
you're gonna fall in love with
delegation because I'm going to talk
about in this video you haven't lost a
delegation and I'm going to talk about
what things you cannot delegate so maybe
one day you can get out of your own way
and build a business and enjoy the
fruits of your labor
okay so law number one when it comes
into the delegation law number one is
delegate up you've got to learn how to
delegate up so what does delegate up
means when we first started the YouTube
channel I can edit so I delegate up we
bring Paul that's delegate up when it
came down to compliance I'm not the best
in compliance we delegate up we got when
and got somebody when it comes out to
all these different projects we're
working on with websites these apps that
costs a million dollars we're designing
right now we can do it so we have
engineers who are experts at code from
all over the world that we delegated up
to and they're producing products that's
insane of a product that produced and
for us because we learn how to delegate
up the better you are at delegating up
the better products you produce the
better systems you create the better
company to create the law number two
number two is while you are delegating
up think about it this way so this
certain task put hours to it will take 8
hours if you do it 12 hours if somebody
else does it so let's go based on 12
hours if this task is going to take 12
hours to do it and it costs you $250
which is 25 bucks an hour to give this
other person to do it but you can do
that eight hours eight hours that's $30
per hour to you 250 are you worth more
than $30 an hour this other person can
do it
with those 12 hours that you have what
can you do to use your 12 hours
effectively to help grow the company
because if you grow the company
this person has more of a steady job and
you can pay more money because your
brain can be in a place to say what can
I do to expand the company and work on
my business I can grow it even to hold
different love you see there's a big
difference in thinking when you learn
how to delegate up and you learn how to
take this task that takes 12 hours put
it effectively in the different area of
your business to grow it law number
three law number three just because
you're best at it there's something you
need to do it just because you're best
at it doesn't mean it to do it a lot of
times you're going to be the best at it
that doesn't mean you need to do it I
can be very very effective and doing
case management work on the complete
other side of the building with our
company I'd be phenomenal at it but I'm
not going to do it the company needs me
to complete it from position then they
need me sitting and doing case manner I
am more effective for the company doing
the work that I'm doing right now
because I don't need to do that
that's called just because I can do it
better than them doesn't mean I need to
be doing it
law number four force yourself not to do
it sometimes it's like an addict you
know it's like an addict they can let go
of something they're addicted to you
have no idea how much control freaks are
are just addicted to doing everything
themselves no no no I'm gonna do myself
and they fire people galore you know how
I know that
I fired 27 assistants in my first two
years of my career 13 years ago you know
why cuz I didn't think any one of my
assistants could do it as good as me
none of them I can do better than
everybody and I was right but I was not
going at the pace I wanted to grow the
moment i delegated i put four or five
assistants around me we just went
through we exploded because I was
finally use of my time and proper areas
to grow the business that effectively
grew everyone else's business and all
those people that were assistants making
a couple grandeur right now you're
making a lot more money so I was
beneficial to everybody if I made a
decision to force myself to not have to
do all the work now let's go to the next
one next one if you're going to delegate
there is one area going to be you're
going to be judged on as a person that's
going to delegate and here's what it is
you will be judged on how you duplicate
a certain person that you delegate a
task to that you no longer
want to do for instance I want to teach
this person how to do front desk
answering the phones
it'll take me 18 hours to teach Bob how
to answer the phones so I'm gonna
roleplay with Bob I need you do this do
this do this do this do this and I'm
gonna role play role play role play you
got it they say this you say this so
this really transfer character that's
pretty easy okay great so let me just
given the numbers let you say take seven
hours so Bob is now doing the front desk
he now has a script we've replayed a
million times he now knows how to do it
I delegate that negotiation anybody that
works here around me we're going to work
very hard are you being a very good
negotiator and learning at what point
not to push at what point to understand
that it's time for us to push at some
point to realize this partner is abusing
us at what point to cut a vendor and say
we are no longer doing business with
this vendor why if you work closely with
me you're going to become a better
negotiator so there'll be many times and
say I want you to listen to this
negotiation called stand right here
listen for the thirty minutes and he
said Stan writing they listen to me I go
through it boom boom boom
I'm duplicating negotiators that may
take a year for me to do but a year
later I'm going to say you handle this
because I duplicated a negotiator I
duplicated a negotiator that I can
delegate that task to which by the way
that person's value also goes higher
when you teach somebody else also learn
certain skills their value goes higher
because you injected your belief your
talent your skill into that person their
value goes are the company's value go
sorry this is a smart thing to do if you
learn how to duplicate other people that
are doing the tasks that you're doing
next match up accordingly so you cannot
match up somebody to do front desk if
they're not very good on front desk and
they just don't like people you can't
match up that's not proper delegation
that's not smart delegation you can't
match up somebody to do business when
they have a short temper
hey I need you to go visit all my
customers and build a relationship with
them okay great they go out there they
piss everybody up they come back why
they would have me wait 20 minutes it's
your customers men you got a waiter
you're cut what are you doing it we just
lost that account I don't care what it
is they made me wait that's a bad
business person you got to match up
accordingly so you can match up just
anybody to delegate any work you need to
know is this the perfect position for
them or you ask
getting a fish to climb a tree what are
you doing with them a fish knows how to
swim that's it you don't ask a fish to
climb the tree like Einstein said many
years ago if you do you're going to make
them feel stupid and they're not stupid
what is their strength delegated
properly in a department that they're
going to be able to max themselves out
number seven number seven inspect until
you trust very simple you can replace
the word inspect as micromanage until
you trust so I want you to take over
this task for me on a weekly basis great
it's three hours a week of work I'm
doing inspect inspect inspect inspect
and span span expect you got it you're
on your own
trust LA number eight beat Kelly be very
clear on what you're expecting so if I'm
delegating XYZ to Bobby I've got to be
clear on what I'm expecting Bobby to do
Bobby I expect you to do boom boom boom
many times we're not clear with the
direction we're given them they're
frustrated because they don't know how
to make you happy or please you there's
friction the friction is on your end
given proper clear expectation to the
other person that you're delegating a
certain responsibility to this has got
to be clear then they got to come back
and you got to ask do I make myself
clear does this make sense to you you
have any questions no I got it perfect
email document go ahead move on and then
you hold them accountable you follow up
with it
number nine stop doing $10 an hour jobs
okay stop doing $10 an hour jobs
yourself and let me explain to what I
mean by stop doing $10 an hour jobs I've
said this on a few other videos before
in the past that I loved ironing and I
love shining my shoes and at one point
even though I couldn't afford I stopped
doing both because I had to increase my
own value now sometimes when people say
that they say well Pat are you saying
that person's worth $10 an hour they may
yes if a person is saying yes to $10 an
hour job that's what they're saying
that's what I'm worth if a person says
yes to $70,000 your job that's what
they're worth if a person saying yes to
$40,000 your job that's what doing now
by the way so you may say so I'm gonna
say no to those job offers then you're
not very smart because if that's truly
your value on the marketplace you say no
that means you're unemployed so what's a
smart what's a wise position for you to
make right so one of the first of all
yes this person is willing to choose to
take this work for $10 and you shouldn't
be doing it as an entrepreneur that want
to scale you need to go into the
why not just a smart say now now now
watch this you better understand that
this person is just as important as
anybody else on the team this is a very
valuable position on what you're doing
if you delegate a responsibility to
somebody and they don't know how
important it is they're not going to do
the work asbestos to their abilities so
you've got to make that very clear with
somebody when you give them certain
tasks for them to do number 10 hire
project managers I like current project
managers right now we're working on a
certain project that's very very big we
don't have the time to do everything
ourselves I have a project manager I
hired from Australia who is the best of
the best he's phenomenal what he does he
gives me reports I know exactly what
he's what's going on he does it sends us
emails we get on a skype we get on a
call I found this guy myself personally
I recruited him he's exceptional and
we're going to do business with them for
many many many years to come initially
was supposed to be 10/10 our job that we
did I think we done so many hours right
now we'll be doing business for the next
10 years together hire project managers
that allows you to do the bigger things
to grow the business nice law last law
here number 11 be a leader be a leader
not a doer of all let me say it again
be a leader not a doer of all a lot of
times we say things like he's a doer he
does everything himself he's a doer he
said you're great be a doer of where you
increase the value of your abilities and
the company and everybody else's the
highest possible be a doer they're not a
be a doer of everything nope be a leader
lead and do the areas that you are very
good at do those things not doing all
when you first start a business you're
going to do all when you first start a
business you're going to do compliance
you can do operation is going to happen
when I first I'm doing ever go she a
ssin customer service front desk issues
complaint I am doing every single thing
you can be thinking about when we first
started every single thing you can be
thinking about I'm doing it but not
eventually then she need to become a
leader you need to not become the doer
of all things in your business so now
let's talk about the things you cannot
delegate I'm gonna get a little bit more
into detail about what you cannot
delegate first things first a high level
skill or behavior now this could be
something you can delegate
eight but this could be also something
you cannot delegate maybe this is your
main skill said that you need to do this
yourself are not delegated it could be
negotiation maybe this is a big deal
that you got to negotiate it could be a
it could be something you do with the
business that that is your area of
expertise when it comes down to certain
numbers tracking something you got to do
that you know the dots on how to come up
with the formula you got to be a part of
you can't just say here you go because
then they're going to come back after 40
hours of putting into it and all the
reports are wrong maybe there's a part
of it you you need to be a part of and
some you don't but you can pretty much
determine what area you can delegate
whatever you cannot it also has a lot to
do with what phase of your business
you're in startup are you in the
survival phase where you have to touch
everything or you more formulation are
you an explosion or your plateau what
phase of your company are you and number
two relationships your best customers
you gotta touch your best customers your
best customers like to do business with
you your best partners your best vendors
and this doesn't mean every single time
I don't deal with my customers and my
vendors every single time but you better
believe I deal with them when it comes
on to important issues I'm involved as
the CEO well my best customers best
vendors best partners number three
Salesforce loyalty it all has to do with
what kind of a company want to build a
lot of times CEOs they don't want to
deal with sales I love dealing with
sales I am I am the happiest when I'm
dealing with sales here's why you take
sales out you're out of business you
better be good to your sales people
because if you don't take you yourselves
people I guarantee somebody else will
like me I am always looking for great
salespeople I will take care of them
take on my work with us here we had a
guy this morning on a conference call
said I can't even believe I'm part of a
company that Pat just gave me a brand
spanking a hardly nightrod special any
gave me a what was the other thing that
we gave him we gave him a Rolex
presidential watch all at the same day
same day picked up this is phenomenal
jason said that earlier today this is
phenomenal when does this happen
we don't have problem doing that because
sales is very very important and I
handle a lot of sales myself because to
me they matter a lot so there's certain
things you cannot delegate when it comes
out to the next for crisis you can't
just say hey we have a crisis you handle
it nope you got to be a part of it hey
we're getting suit you got to be a part
of it hey we have this you've got to be
hey we got
complaint you got to be part you cannot
let crisis go because sometimes there
may be a small complaint that you're not
willing to address because you don't
think it's a big deal then all of a
sudden boom boom boom boom boom becomes
this big now you cannot solve it anymore
you could have solved it easily if you
got involved earlier and just said tell
me about the prom pop up about let me
make a three calls
we're good to go number five negotiation
you do kind of said that earlier a
little bit number five big-ticket items
so a lot of times you know depending on
your company standard you may say any
purchase is up to ten thousand dollars
needs the president's approval and CFOs
approval anything above twenty thousand
dollars needs my approval great hey
we're thinking about doing this at
seventy three thousand dollars no with
them are doing this at seventy two
thousand dollars and I have a very
simple system if you come to me and you
say we have a purchase to make that's
fifty thousand dollars I'll always say
do we have three different options no go
get two other options then it come back
we got three different proposals here
okay great let me look at them seventy
three but gives this sixty eight but
gives that but fifty two however this
fifty two they're newer they don't know
what they're doing but it's twenty
thousand dollars - I'm not comfortable
with this let's go here okay great
awesome
now you move on but the finances you
touch because you got to make a decision
as a CEO to talk with your CFO about
that but that's purely your decision
last one is the heartbeat behind a brand
the heartbeat behind the brand is the
leader the CEO the entrepreneur the
visionary you're the heartbeat behind
the brand you've got to be touching the
stuff that's the heartbeat behind a
brand you know the story you may be the
founder you've touched it you grew this
thing you are completely vested in the
heartbeat you got to participate in a
heartbeat heartbeat has to do how people
see the company how people view the
company how's the story being told the
mission the vision that the vid you
can't just say you guys go put the nice
mission statement vision save all this
stuff and then bring it and I'll approve
it you got to be part of it and that's a
part of it you got to be part of so
those are some of the things that here
in this video the title may have said
why millionaires are not as smart as you
think they are well they're extremely
wise that's why they become millionaires
millionaires don't become millionaires
because they have no clue what they're
doing they're extremely wise and they
realize they need a big team and if you
eventually want to become a millionaire
you need to realize you need to leverage
delegate and find good people around you
that you
ring up with you and you win big where
eventually your business everybody
that's a part of it wins as well with
that being said Paul throw me just that
pillow right there throw me just that
pillow right there
gang if you haven't subscribed to this
channel please do so we have a goal of
getting 2 million subs it's a lofty goal
we have by end of 2017 we want to get 2
million subscribers by the end of 2017
subscribe if you have not yet feel free
to share this video with anybody else
that you're working with could be an
executive that can also value from this
company from this video and last but not
least if if if by any chance you have an
idea for pillow we are recruiting a new
pillow today this pillow is going to be
retired effective December 31st 2016 we
need a new pillow for 2017 if you're
creative if you're somewhat competitive
send us a new clear we've already got a
ton of pillows we're going to choose one
pillow that's going to replace this for
all of 2017 in our videos and if we
choose your pillow we'll give you a love
for choosing your pillow say your name
put the pillow on here and you'll get
love for choosing a pillow for 2017 you
got to send a pillow to 5001 Spring
Valley Road Suite 11:55 East you can
take a picture of it on the screen shot
that's Dallas Texas zip code 75606 for
watching
[Music]
you